welcome back to poppy playtime chapter
two we're going back into the toy
factory and i know that there was a lot
of drama to do with the company behind
this game so i'm gonna be your lightning
rod of hate please direct all of your
hate and vitriol straight my way i can
take it it's not because i'm a masochist
i just want to know how much i can take
so if you feel the need to spew
vitriol at me i am ready and waiting for
all of it to pour over me like a
waterfall
of hate
guys live my favorite quote from um
whose line is it anyway way back in the
day um
yeah i'm so ready anyway uh today is a
momentous occasion it's an incredible
occasion it's a wondrous fantastical
occasion in which we get to explore the
factory of poppy playtime together
and uh subject ourselves to horrors
unknown and i am your humble guide along
with only me
and maybe whatever is standing behind me
are gonna accompany you into this
factory and we're gonna see exactly
how insane we could possibly be boom
ah chapter two
fly
in a web
with poppy now free what
the situation begin
hey hi twitchy how you doing
uh the situation begins to ch
change rapidly while you search for any
way to escape
the factory
now i don't know about you
but that sounds ominous and as far as
[Music]
all right
as far as ominous things goes i'm not
unfamiliar with a little omninity i
don't think that's the correct
terminology for it but if you are
unfamiliar with the omnimity you need to
go back and see chapter one or you need
to cuddle up turn out the lights grab a
blanket and get ready for the spooks now
before i go any further i want to make
sure that this is an adequate experience
for everybody are you able to hear me
clearly over the game clearly right now
there's just music going on i don't want
it fighting over another i'm a bad
streamer i'm a worse youtuber and i want
to make sure that the volume is adjusted
perfectly because the only thing i care
about in life is audio
so is it all good loud and clear
everything's coming through hot and
heavy
nice and twitchy
[Music]
anyway to recap what happened before we
made our way into this factory for
unknown reason we grabbed a backpack
that could shoot out arms left and right
and oddly enough it's kind of
coincidental to what i'm seeing in front
of me and i'm wondering if there's some
kind of connection to that back cap
backpack and the character that is in
the thumbnail on this video
but i'm assuming that's going to be told
in this and the other thing that i'd
like to say is i'm back
baby
baby i'm back i'm on a roll i'm
officially back from my vacation uh
after the release of in space with
markiplier so i'm happy to do this i
just released a video a little earlier
of me playing the entirety of the
stanley parable ultra deluxe which
people were asking for and now i'm gonna
play this because these are the two
things that people wouldn't stop
shouting about
and you know me i'm a people pleaser
i love doing exactly what people want
nothing to the contrary to that so
whatever you want is what i deliver
i'm here for you to do what you want
actually i do want to play this so it's
totally fine all right everybody's in
here let's go for it
uh
hold any button to skip why would i do
that i learned my lesson from uh the
stanley purple
hello
am i am i not
[Music]
co's new patented elastic plastic you
can stretch pull and twist mommy
longlegs in the craziest ways
she loves watching you play when you're
having fun she's having fun
the new mommy longlegs from playtime co
hello what's the time
wake up
oh
hi wake up
i i'm pretty sure that i'm awake
are there subtitles in this game
oh yeah absolutely this is
the nft game
i don't even know what happened with all
that i know that people got very upset
and perfectly understandable i'm not a
big fan of nfts either are there
subtitles in this
um but as far as i know they kind of
stopped doing that so honestly who knows
what's going on with that
i do not see
subtitle option
well that's a pain in the dick but okay
i guess i'll
just uh swallow my own pride and uh play
on don't worry i'll say out loud exactly
what is going on and remember
i am your lightning rod of hate please
direct it all towards me
yeah all right um
do i have a flashlight i remember this
this stuff right at the end of the last
chapter we did end up in some kind of a
house and i don't remember why i don't
even know if it was explained why but i
do vaguely remember a cabinet that had
something spooky in it in fact i
remember a lot of things in this game
that might have had something spooky
inside or around it
so into this game i go
flap
i do love these hands just as a mechanic
it's just very fun
and now i don't remember i don't
remember how
really use them
also i must be a
must be a child or something because
this is quite a low perspective even
lower than what i'm used to
oh hello
oh
back in the factory already so is there
any reason that there's kind of a house
thing
right next to the factory which also if
i remember had all those crazy conveyor
belts going every which way
is that what it is
144p
144p crank it up to 1080. i'm
broadcasting at 1080.
there shouldn't be any reason you should
be watching this 144p
unless that's the experience that you
want out of youtube and then fine you
want to make everything an analog [ __ ]
go for it
you know what honestly i don't even care
about the lore
i'm just here to have a good time and
get spooked a few times
oh that's
excuse you
excuse you
who's whispering at me
why is this
why is this toy covered in blood
or oil depending on which one you
depending on if you're a glass half
empty or glass half full kind of guy oh
is that a vent cover for up there
nope
i don't think so wham
okay
elliot ludwig
okay
keep going says you
says you nerd
show you's going all right fine i'll
keep going
look i don't need your guidance
i know what i'm doing
okay but how in the hell am i going to
get it up
how do i oh boy oh i don't need to
that i can just
if i just pull it
then i should be able to use it as a
ramp
this is what people call a big brain
move
which is what i'm all about
press here all right
yes
give me a big squeeze
i promise i won't bite
[Music]
what kind of a promise are you making
here
give me a big squeeze yeah i don't think
i will say
sure thing pal sure thing pal
sure thing pal
what i can pull barrels but i can't pull
those things off
hello
what a lovely flower it's a key actually
if you think about it oh
key
all right fine then
power
overload overload
overload it no all right fine then
so if i have a key it must go to the
door
i'm assuming anyway
another bloody toy
okay goodbye
i'm assuming that this red key with the
red flower must go to the red door
with the red floor
i love him her them i love them
oh this is weird wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute
hold on here
a pink huggy wuggy is that when i'm
huggy and
kissy
stay the [ __ ] away from me forever kissy
okay i'm saying no preemptively kissy
all right oh i wonder i wonder
the 5th of november
wait a minute
wait wait a minute hold on a second here
hold on a ha a gosh darn minute
let me get this out of the way
i think this is a secret
i think i'm supposed to go this way
my gamer instincts are really kicking in
can i push yes i can
i wish i could just pick things up but
apparently i can't do that all right
hello
can i crouch yeah i can crouch can i
crouch jump it's a question
okay so i gotta use my big brain here
come here come here you wanna come here
you know you wanna come here
okay i gotta use my even bigger brain
here you come here come here this is
extremely worth it for those that are
saying this isn't worth it you're wrong
and uh who's been doing youtube for 10
years now that's me
that would be me that would be this
person right here yes yes good yes
excellent good
yes yes yes yes
yes
no no bad wrong yes no stop what are you
doing
just get up here
oh damn you
hmm
okay well that's not really working
but that
but that's never stopped me before
get
up you damn you
come on
stack on top of the other one
this would be much easier if i
had been doing this yet that doesn't
make any sense the way you're doing what
you're doing
doesn't make any sense at all actually
so if i can scoop and then jump and hit
it with my nog come on
maybe you maybe you maybe i can use you
come here you come here are you
yes
yes no
invisible wall
oh
oh there's nothing over there wow okay
whatever oh
there's nothing
there's hello what did i get
what
hello i don't know what did i get
what
no no i don't know what happened am i
breaking the game i might be i might be
breaking the game
hello you have no eyes
okay there's a vcr here and i remember
that something about
if i find it oh tape
ah dave
playtime co is the product of a great
man by the name of elliot ludwig
divorced but a family man at heart
his sights were always set on bringing
amazing toys to amazing children around
the globe
ludwig spent countless hours in the
factory working overtime relentlessly in
an attempt to continuously innovate and
surprise
in the 1960s an unfortunate family death
had pushed ludwig down to his lowest but
with so much ambition he rose back up
and continued to fulfill his vision for
the playtime code toy factory
ludwig could never be content leaving a
project unfinished but just how did one
man come to create such an astounding
empire how did he manage to stay
determined even after suffering such a
tragic loss
it all began in the fateful year of 19.
87.
was that the ludwig of 87
all right whatever i'm going in the vent
i'm assuming that death will not be
following me the moment that i get in
here
but you know i've been wrong before so
i'm assuming i'll be wrong again
even though time has not quite perfected
my ability to play games properly
but whatever it's fine
hello
die death death die kill it murder
if i saw that
in real life
i would be trying to kill it so fast
that is not a child
that is a demon
and therefore
you should try to destroy it anyway
ow
oh right i need to do the rap beef thing
here we go
okay and then this
uh
no yes no maybe so
i need to touch something else i think
ah this hi y'all
hiya all right hi yeah
don't clap at me
um i wanted to thank you for freeing me
uh-huh i was stuck in there for so long
uh-huh thank you
i'd like to pay you back
you'd like to pay yeah okay
i can't hear you
what
what did you say something about train
station
you're expecting me to follow you
you demon
what where are you where's that voice
coming from
oh my god die
death whoa hello
hey hey hey oh cool
all right guy i'll kill you i'll
strangle you with my long hands
you die you should be sad look at your
face i'd be sad if i had a face like
that oh yeah
fine all right don't worry i'll i'm
gonna i'm gonna get you oh i'm gonna get
to y'all right oh i'm gonna get to you
oh don't you worry
i'm gonna get to you
you just stay right there don't worry
don't worry
what is happening
something tells me i'm not supposed to
be trying to build
build a letter of everything
something tells me that i might not be
doing this right but you know what hey
i'm a big smart guy
hoping ah god damn you your stupid pipe
doesn't want to grab anymore hi-yah
hi
hi yeah
okay fine
okay don't you worry don't you worry
don't you worry i got this
okay i just need to crouch and then jump
all right there's got to be another way
i know people are just wailing and the
gnashing of teeth is occurring at this
very moment but uh to be perfectly
honest i did say that i was going to be
a lightning rod of hate
at the beginning of this uh adventure
and uh i'm just hoping to live up to
those it's a ladder
it's not a ladder
that looks like a ladder
but it's
not a ladder
don't worry guys
i'm on the job
hello
no
don't worry guys
i'm on the job
you're dead now
what am i doing i don't even know if i
was supposed to come up here was i
supposed to come up here
i don't recall ha-yah all right made it
this is where i'm supposed to go right
no
the dark the darkness inside
the darkness
the darkness is consuming me that's not
right the darkness no
yeah whatever it's a dumb joke anyway
what am i supposed to do
i literally couldn't hear you before you
said it so i really don't know this is
the kind of [ __ ] that lixian would
ordinarily cut out but unfortunately
everybody uh subjected to my own
stupidity for a prolonged experience
i can really hear the wailing and
gnashing of teeth
it's quite loud
hmm
door is a door
door
door
no not door hmm
you no
definitely not that
[Music]
i'm gonna wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute i'm seeing a path
ah
i've i've connected it
i've connected it come here you come
here you know come here you
here we go
everybody
this is what people call
a big brain move so i'm here right and
then i go here right and then i go over
here right and then i go here right and
then i go down here and then i go here
right and then i jump up onto
and then i jump up onto it
and then i jump up
and then i jump up
and then i then i then i jump up onto
then then i then i jump up onto
then i jump up onto
then i jump up
then i jump up die die i don't
god damn it
well i almost had you but i will not be
thwarted again
because i
i'm really good at this game
hold it
hold hold
hold
hold
hold
hold
pause everyone just
shut off your brains for a moment don't
you worry
can you believe that i'm the same guy
that made fun of uh
ships for being bad at games
can you believe i'm that same guy
you believe this is the guy
come on come on now
i swear this worked before
okay
oh yeah
no
oh yeah wait what if i even better move
even bigger brain move
genius
genius move about to happen
genius move okay watch this
then i push this over onto that tip it
so that i can then
pull it onto that
so then i can make an angled entry
upwards on onto hello
there we go angled entry up over here
now i've got a perfect path to go over
here jump onto this thing go over here
crouch down here reach over
launch my hands across the room
to latch on
to that
what
what
what
hold on
i jump over here i go over here i look
at this i jump down here i
will never look at chat not not on your
life why would i ever do that i am stuck
oh i'm free
i will literally
you cannot pay me to look at what you're
writing whatever it is it's definitely
not worth my time because i have already
solved it i have solved it
solved it
solved it it happened before it can
happen again
it happened before it can happen again
somehow i got it
and it'll happen again it's going to
happen it'll happen this is how it's
going to happen everybody is going to
happen i see chat moving over in the
side i'm not looking at it
why would i do that why would i look at
it why would i ever look at it why would
i ever look at it because this is
exactly how the the the game developers
intended for this to go
just like this
it's almost too perfect
it's a pixel perfect move where you have
to
shoot it on the crouch on releasing
crouch to get it over and then grasp on
to the thing that's across the room
how did i get that
literally how did i get that lesson okay
anyway
let me try going in here again okay this
clearly isn't it
this is a toughy this might be the
toughest puzzle in all of gaming history
really tough right here
so if i had to think about this and if
i'm really thinking about this then
there must be something that it wants me
to do to either get up to where she is
maybe the trick was trying to strangle
her
death die death die
death
die
dad
die
maybe the trick was maybe the real trick
was the friends we made along the way
or the enemies
die
death
die death
die death i will never look
over to my left
i don't know how you cannot understand
this
i
no look
i never look i see it's just a blur it's
a blur of text i'm never going to look i
said at the very top of this oh you
could pour all your vitriol onto me
it fuels me i'm just seeing how much i
can take
the perfect strategy has appeared before
mine eyes
the truth was in front of me all along
all i needed to do was use the tool it
gave me
ah
yeah
yeah all right fine that didn't work uh
that was a joke i didn't actually mean
for that to be the thing that you
thought you'd have to be a fool to think
that that was actually the thing that
you thought i wanted the latter
all along
i knew it i always knew
i always come back to the ladder i got
this guys don't worry about a thing
[Laughter]
watch this
get ready uh start recording this get
ready to clip it because this is going
to be
what if
it's been in front of me all along
the ladder was already up here i moved
it off of this place that it needed to
be
guys that was my bad i should have
recognized it this was supposed to be up
here because that's where it originally
was this just goes to show my
adventurous nature actually works
against me sometimes
[Laughter]
i had everything i needed and you know
it's just my own fault i i i made it too
complicated see my brain was trying to
make it uh
like bigger than it really was when in
reef
get up here when in reality it was much
simpler like the answer was directly in
front of me all along
okay just a little more certainty on
getting that there
there we go
oh
hey
hey come back
come on now
okay you come here you come here you you
come here you you come here you you come
on come on come on over here come on up
here what are you doing
there you go
perfect
and voila
uh look where'd it go
that look that look
she's giving me what is that look
good
god that look
is the scariest thing
that is the scariest look
i've ever seen
all right so i made it up here mission
accomplished everybody mission
accomplished
so uh what did you want from me
you have the tiniest hands i don't trust
that at all
did you want me to follow you
like go back
did you want me to go back
did did you want me to go back
maybe
hey i'm up here
oh
i don't like that concept um i don't
really appreciate that in fact if i had
been able to hear you or if there were
subtitles i might have understood that
you wanted me to go back but uh you know
it's like i should have understood i
always
go back is uh the quote that everyone
loves anyway
pish posh that was fun actually i
thought that was a pretty tough puzzle
but uh to be perfectly honest like i'm a
bit too smart for some of these puzzles
i feel like they could make it a little
more challenging
i'm sorry is there a demon
chanting
somewhere up above
hello
god i am
don't let them near you what the floor
isn't that the problem no you guess
you're right when i fall into a pit
not to let them near
anywho
all right
where am i i better go back you know
that's uh pretty sure i've probably got
to go back all the way to in there solve
that puzzle again and then i'll come
back around to that
[Music]
you here well i probably have to do the
whole thing over again don't worry guys
i got this
i'm sorry man
i'm really taking this lightning rod of
hate
a little too seriously
it was all a joke guys you know that
whole time before
that old time before that was just you
know i knew exactly what to do from the
very beginning and you know i just
wanted to uh
do a little trolling you know
that's how i am maybe if i do both
no
okay
let's try this again
okay
the spider-man swinging is gonna take a
little getting used to i'm not 100 sure
how good it's gonna be in the near
future but uh
a buzzy bee that's me uh you're [ __ ]
dead uh sorry your eyeballs got exploded
out of you i don't know if you're a
buzzy bee at all hello are you here yeah
probably broken
peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo hello
oh my god
jump
jump in jump push push i push you
me too
oh oh god hello
oh okay cool well that was
that actually wasn't what i expected i
fully expected to die 100 going into
that hole
um but now that i think about it
considering that i didn't explore
anything prior to that uh makes 100
sense
and i'm sure that there were definitely
no secrets that i missed before eddie m
and r
leith pierre elliott ludwig stella grape
they all have these
slides can i go up one of them
oh really invisible wall are you serious
oh
it you couldn't have just put shutters
on those you really put an invisible
wall like oh we would never expect
someone to go back up no one would be
that stupid i'm playing of course i'm
that stupid
let me be that stupid
okay who whose name fell off here
[Music]
let's see here there's letters on the
ground we've got
j a h
y e o i and write this down write this
down write this down we've got j a h y e
o
markiplier
okay cool it's my slide
wham
wham
no whim
hey
ah i see aren't you just a savage
okay
all right guys we got ourselves a puzzle
the only answer is to throw ourselves
into the abyss that's the only way guys
it's the only way
all right okay guys just hold on
we've got a puzzle
we have
a puzzle
now the trick of this puzzle
is clearly
to
get the power in a way that doesn't i've
got it
i've got it
i have it
i have it genius genius genius genius
genius level ultimate ultra level genius
[Laughter]
that's what you get developers
you made it too easy
you didn't expect that i would be
playing
you didn't expect this brain would be
coming into this arena
you weren't ready for this
i know
i got it
god man you know i think this game might
be made for babies
[Laughter]
anyway i'm gonna go high-five that thing
because i am a winner
and uh this definitely is an anonymous
hallway where
don't hold by
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
how is that fun
instead why don't we make a game out of
it
the game station is still working
it will be just like old time
all three slaps
i'll give you the train code
mommy loves that idea puppy
you're going to have so much fun
head to musical memory and mommy will
get things started
obey the rules
and eat your insides
while you're still alive
so what i heard from that exchange is
that
she was gonna
eat my insides
she was gonna
all right
you know what
not so bad i would trust
spaghetti lady before i trust that tiny
uh chucky doll
i would trust oh this way i would trust
that
let's just call her lady spaghetti for
now i would trust lady spaghetti a
million ways a thousand weighs more than
this demon child
a million trillion ways more so uh
you know
lady spaghetti she's she's all right in
my wooded i just pick up what what what
was happening
oh god oh my god what are you what are
you demon oh god
all right um
oh
well okay that's fun um you're coming
with me
uh just uh it's just a just to pop down
on his luck you know uh let's go for a
walk
let's go for a walk pooch oh
come on boogie
come on bobby where'd you go puppy
where'd you go
come on bobby we're going to go for a
walk you want to go to the park
you want to go to the game station oh
you want to go puppy come on
we're going for a ride i think i think
we need to
go somewhere
all right puppy come here boy come here
i can't
i used to be able to i i was talented
once it
ow yeah come here boy
uh it's dead so is my talent so um
yeah you stay there i'm gonna take some
rides
horsey no
well
this is
this is lovely
this is adorable
[Music]
what in the heck in hell
okay
anyway i'm gonna keep playing
was this power wash simulator
we
uh
we
all right anyway
i'm gonna go now
oh boy teeter-totter come on puppy let's
go whoa you're so excited well now calm
down now oh you you uh you calm down i'm
gonna get you out don't worry you're
gonna hop on you know come on noodle
don't be shy yeah you sitting all
daughter you don't have a choice in this
all right you sit right there whoa come
on now
whoa
hey
calm down
get on the teeter-totter
get on the see-saw
i
the see-saw is [ __ ]
all right fine
whatever come on puji
come here boy
come on boy
what else we got oh you want to go on
the whirly slide
all right you stay there you play you'd
be good play play dead
can i go god why why can't i twist
myself into oblivion
can i go up here
why can't i go up there you're going to
give me a whole a whole parked plane
you're not going to let me actually play
in it i can play it i can't play in it
this is some [ __ ]
now this is some [ __ ] here we go
here we go
all right
okay and
that oh okay
i don't know what that was
okay fine screw this i'm out of here
this is a
boring ass place anyway
i didn't want to what is up there
whoa
is uh
spaghetti ladies who's kind of like has
a nest or something oh no idea
come here
what's this statues statutes that stat
statues
was i supposed to be collecting
something this whole time
whack-a-wuggy
musical memory
wasn't that what i was supposed to do go
to musical memory
hello
don't need to tell me twice
hi kids welcome to the game station
i'm stella and we've got three super
duper fun games to play stella these
little tests show us here
and we'll start by playing musical
memory
see you in a bit
okay
okay
okay all right
sure on boogie
we're going to musical memory where'd
you go
oh
how did you get ahead of me
that's terrible
okay i heard that there was a musical
memory here
some kind of musically memorable stuff
i know when your birthday is
june 28th
[Music]
it's a wish
[Music]
happy birthday to you
[Music]
okay all right well i'm assuming that
you just googled that because that's
pretty public information
i know when your birthday is
june 28th
[Music]
you just you just have a nap you you
just stay down there you know you stay
there come on puppy i'm i want to speak
to the manager of this establishment i
want to speak to the i want to speak to
somebody about this
i'm going to breach your privacy weed
poppy
yeah puppy will be there when i get back
okay i love that the kids have to go
through this
mine shaft
well that's too obvious
clearly i'm
supposed to hit these all right fine
what have you got
hello
[Music]
well i don't have another hand am i
supposed to mold myself a hand
oh wait whoa hey stop hold on there
there's a tape here
hold on can you shut up could you shut
up
could you shut up
could you shut
oh
ten seconds
[Music]
oh
okay
sure
what's what's the time plate okay
whatever all right so i need to make
myself a green hand so this is just a
series of buttons right
oh
it's broken
let's just wrench that back into place
all right what else is broken before i
have to do this it's going to go up
through there into the whatever the hell
that is with its long legs and then it's
going to go over here it's going to go
into the mashy muncher high five bro
and you're going to go down there and
then you're going to do something rather
than i don't know i'll see the problem
when i get to it
go
explain to me how that makes hands
properly
okay
okay
what
no painting machine
well why didn't you load it then how is
this my fault
i thought something was bashing its way
into this door i didn't know something
was bashing its way into that door
safety first not liable
what
where what is happening
yeah whatever i don't care
hello
hi it's me why is the back door open
here why is this
sorry just had a seizure for a moment
there why is this back door open
hmm
is that a golden hand wait what was that
oh yeah
yeah
hi
i got a golden hand i don't know what to
do about that but people seem to love
collectibles if there's one thing i
learned from the stanley parable is that
people really love collectibles
uh slam
simple as that everybody simple as that
what is that
why don't they give me a flashlight hand
that'd be useful
hello
hello
oh god okay nothing over there can i
jump into the hand machine
i can
that doesn't do anything high five
high fives all right whatever
bam
at least i have backups this time
oh okay
thank you
wow
is there another door in here that i
need to do this to or is this the only
one
so what was that about uh untimely
deaths oh i probably have to do them ah
no i shouldn't i should i shouldn't i'm
indecisive
they lied to me
they lied to me
i can't believe they did
why would they lie to me the danger was
never real to begin with
i'm here trying to destroy myself
in irresponsible ways and they don't
even allow it
they lied to me
lag
i can't believe it
can't believe any of this
i want to speak to the manager of this
establishment please
i would like to have a long firm
conversation
i bet i can hop this fence
i bet i can off this fence i bet i can't
i bet i can
oh i so can okay
okay
perfect okay let's get you first off get
you
onto you
okay hold on hold on i bet i can do this
i bet it's so worth to do this unless
they put an invisible wall at the top of
this i no i've ruined everything i give
up
i ruined everything never mind
uh you'll never you'll never be right up
again i don't know why you even bother
and for the record yes june 28th is my
birthday
hello oh
welcome to musical memory
this advanced memory and cognitive
recognition test is designed to
stimulate several segments of the brain
allowing us to see how quickly and
efficiently your brain works
a sequence of colors will be shown and
you must recreate the exact sequence
using the buttons around you
bonzo will slowly lower towards you
when you complete a color pattern
correctly bunzo will rise back up
when you input a pattern incorrectly
bunzo will lower towards you faster
if bunzo reaches you your test is over
the test will become more difficult as
it continues with longer patterns in
quicker succession
that's all
good luck
okay all right you know what hey bonzo
you think you know what birthday it is
did you see the creator isn't it amazing
what mommy hasn't seen the place i've
been running in
can only years
how excited bonzo must be
oh my god stop stop
stop stop stop stop
stop
stop
stop stop
oh that's the dinner bell
good luck
all right bunzo hey you want to fight
buddy you want a fight you want a five
bonzo good thing my brain is impeccable
red now now
red red
red red
red
red
red
[Music]
red
red
red
[Music]
red
red
yellow red
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
green red
green
red green red green
green red green green
green red green green
green red green green blue
green red a green green blue
green red green green blue violet
green red green green blue
violet
[Music]
can't trick me with that one
oh god
blue white
blue white violet blue white violet
blue white violet light
blue white violet white
blue white violet white
blue white violet white white
oh god
blue blue
[Music]
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
blue jay
heart pie pie
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
hahahahaha
that's no fun
for doing such a splendid job
mommy has decided to give you
part of the code for the train
what if i don't
what if i don't
[Laughter]
they literally didn't account for any
possibility that someone would not take
this
code you just uh you gonna dangle there
from
hey you're right
okay
uh
what if i don't
well i was just i'm just saying what
about
what if i don't
listen you gonna make me huh make me
take it
make me take it
good man the tension in here all right
fine
mommy was hoping the game could last a
little longer
it's okay though
mommy knows other ways to play with you
it's not it
it's not just me right
it's it's it's not just me right
the energy that i'm picking up
it's like
really heavy-handed right
i'm not into that okay
all right it's a little coming on a
little strong there
all right okay
it's not just me
it's not just me
right
yeah i didn't think so and it's uh
no thank you you know what i'm saying
about that no thank you you don't quite
have the um how do i how do i say this
uh power
that i'm looking for okay you kind of a
little flimsy if you know what i mean
much like this
real
all right
that's too obvious
you're not gonna catch me with that one
that was too obvious
you think there's gonna be a light in
the handle that's gonna be glowing red
that i'm gonna fall in no way
that's the easy path i'm going to take
the hard path there's got to be
something i can stack in here
i bet i can climb back up this way stack
it properly if i use some kind of an
exploit i probably can find somewhere to
wedge my all right fine i'll go in this
thing
fine
fine
if i use this i can probably use it to
wedge myself up
and over
all right never mind then
i really want to break this game but
this game just doesn't want me to break
it
look look i'm not saying anything i'm
not saying anything look lady spaghetti
sure
if that's your type that's fine i'm just
saying you know
not quite the power you know what i'm
talking about not quite the power you
know
i can't really respect that power it's
not the same not the same it's kind of
close but not the same
i'm assuming that nothing's following me
because that would be
nope
it's not really letting me grab anything
but i want to break it now
i want to break it not fine
wow
sir
he really poops god lunas on his episode
of poopsie sparkly critters was that it
oh my god i love that one
god i love that one
good times good times
well if you spit or will she poop she
poop is this supposed to be like a dig
at five nights at freddy's because i see
the top hat and i see the bear here and
you know it just it feels morning
pooping hazard it feels like a little
on the nose
if if like when i pressed this nose it
honked i would think that would be more
of a reference
listen listen bobby play diamond
what do you got an equivalent of the
bite of 87 in here wanna hear a dino
joke click once for the question click
again for the punchline
[Music]
what do you call a dino with one eye
nope
i'm not even going to listen to the pun
i'm not going to listen
kick me ball
nobody likes it
kick me
[Laughter]
i love kick me paul
i love kick me paul
look it kick me paul
nah i don't love him that much
oh
i'm sorry you asking me to climb up you
because i won't apparently
fine
oh damn it
i was so close
give
mine
really really i
i feel like that should be mine
i feel like that should be mine
fine i'll go this way
you're ex your what for me you are
i heard something very different than i
think what was actually said and i am
not going to repeat what i think i heard
are you speaking english
am i having a stroke
[Music]
[Music]
i hear root the second time
when she emphasizes it
the first word
i am not hearing that
anyway imma go now hey big red button
no no
what is happening oh you're too heavy
okay fine i get it
hmm okay so there's gotta be something
here that i can uh do
oh
incinerate kick me paul launch with
avery fry call retail stores to return
spa shipments
okay oh uh
do we have to do
hello do we have a tutorial somewhere
here
all right there's gotta be um some kind
of a tape here that i've missed someone
keep your eyes peeled i don't want to be
delaying this too long i don't want
people to get bored
as i make no progress i would hate that
to happen i would absolutely despise
that
that'd be the worst thing that could
happen to me
a youtube
a youtuber of sorts
there can't be a moment
of uh
dead air here it would just be a tragedy
imagine if me a professional youtuber
we're just stuck on the same puzzle over
and over and endlessly over again
never making progress can you imagine it
guys
well after 10 years of
doing these let's plays i can proudly
say that i am not like those other
youtubers
i am
good at my job and i am just fantastic
when it comes to delivering quality
content that people love and deserve
i think this should be mine
this absolutely 100 should be mine that
there's no reason that that
i see it with mine own eyes
i see the truth now
i need to power that thing
and once i power that thing that should
be mine
it it should be mine
there's no way that this should not it's
not give it to i'm literally here
give it to me
you
you a [ __ ]
okay
i wanted you to know that
i wanted you to know that okay i know
what to do
hold on everybody
i'm charged up
wait no stop don't do it yet don't do it
yet give it to me
well do your thing why aren't you doing
it do your thing
damn it
nope
okay and then
what do i do do i get a screw the switch
or something oh
really
this game really thought that i needed
it to do all of that
all of that nonsense
for me just to get that
i was
literally there i i
i was literally there and i had that and
um
i hate that
i was right there okay but clearly i
need to move this somewhere so that i
can um can i not have that be stuck down
okay so there's got to be something else
that this needs to grab right
that's the whole crux of this
so what in this wild world oh
duh
doy come here you
come here
elmo oh
let's go pal let's go
i love industrial worker simulator
this is fantastic wham
come here you
drop it on my head
slam it on my nog
it's probably something else that i need
to do with this i feel like
you live there now
you live there now
i am
oh you're saying that i'm not as hefty
as that dino
is that what you're saying
you think that i the director of an
organization whose sole purpose is to
track down mark e playa
notorious international criminal wanted
in 87 different countries
is that very criminal standing directly
in front of you so you really believe
what am i doing here
oh that's what i'm doing healthy bodies
healthy workers
playtime co recommends 30 minutes of
exercise daily employees not permitted
to exercise during work well
this just reeks
of funtime chica
awfully suspicious if you really think
about it which i am
oh how do i get down ha i don't need to
get down wham
i'm sure blam
uh
so do i gotta get up and down before i
do that
what if i
hold on i'm braining
interesting
okay so what i gotta do is i just gotta
be quick about it
come here come here
i'm the king of quick god damn it
okay
all right then
how about that
[Laughter]
all right cool
easy peasy
show me something tough
show me something monstrous
something i can't overcome
i have been doing
scary game let's plays
for over 10 years
you think
that a little bit of more steam is gonna
get in my way is gonna get a reaction
out of me do you know
how many other jumpscares i have faced
in my time of being a youtuber you think
oh you think your little steam joke is
gonna get me
i am dead inside and if you think you're
gonna come into my video and make me
jump from that [ __ ] you got another
thing coming to you
okay have a nice day okay thank you
anyway happy 10 years to me been doing
let's plays a long time
guys
yeah come on
i see you
oh i'm back up here
poochie
yeah
ectoplasm
the the the tunnel is blocked by all
this
ectoplasm who'd uh who'd have thought it
would be here um
god all the ectoplasmic goo
i guess some kind of a ghost came
through here huh all right
well anyway
what's next
what's up with you anyway i don't like
your departure
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
i missed i'm i'm missing somehow
yeah okay
this is the toughest minigame of this
okay all right i just gotta get the
right angle
got it
why was that so hard why was that so
hard you did fantastic
who gave you permission to be this smart
mommy is super proud of you but i'm sure
she's already told you that herself
our next game is
head downstairs and have fun
okay all right then
well it seems cathartic
okay
i don't like all these different colored
woogies
it makes me think that there might be
some more monstrosities coming my way
grow happy healthy kids
i hate this
are you
are you suggesting that huggy wuggy is
spaghetti ladies
kid
something like that also why'd they have
to give her boobs
like that
we had a crash
am i still alive yes i'm fine it's okay
everything's fine
grab pack storage why
why would i need that do i need that is
that something that i need
do i need that
is that something that i need
do i need it can i get it
i bet i can get it
but there's some way that i can get it
okay if i can get something up here that
trash can
come here
i bet i can get
one of these times it's going to flip up
in just the right way
that allows me
oh i was faked out but it's okay because
i'm going about it the wrong way
it's so obvious now that i think about
it if i could get this properly
yeah nope hold on hold on
perfect yes exactly what i needed ah
exactly what i needed
then i take this and i move it up here
i throw it around up here and if i can
get it wedged perfectly
up
exactly right
now that i've wedged that perfectly
i can huh
well it's nothing all right goodbye then
i didn't want to be here anyway
i didn't want to be here anyway what am
i here to have what is this
what am i looking at here i'm looking at
like sand
oh
hello
welcome to wakka waggy
this advanced test is designed to assess
the extent of your reactionary abilities
a dual palm grab pack will be provided
to you for this test
around you are 18 sizable holes
an adorable huggy wuggy toy could appear
out of any one of these holes
if one comes out hit it with your grab
pack
[Music]
that's all
good luck
oh
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh it's like it's like half tryptophobia
used to have strings attached to them
so they could be pulled back when they
got too close to the children
have fun
okay all right i'll have fun
show you fun
i'll show you all kinds of fun
are they going to make a noise when they
come out
is that the noise
so i saw something oh
oh i see you
i can't see him
i hear oh there you are get out here
get out of here
get out of here
come on louden up a little bit
get out of here
get out of here
here's something back here
oh my god this is awful
i hate this get out here
nope no
i hear that where's that coming from
oh god oh god that's awful whoa
whoa
oh my god nope nope
nope
nope nope not happening not dealing with
that
we're not doing that today
we're not doing it we're not doing it
nope get out
get out i don't want it we don't want it
nobody wants it
nobody wants it i will not have it
get out of here
who is there
get out of here
i hate you
nope
nope
nope
nope
nope
nope
nope
nope nope nope nope
nope nope
nope nope
nope
nope nope nope nope
nope nope
nope nope
nope oh god i'm dead
all right
okay
you want to go you want to go huh
turn up the volume so i can actually
hear it
bear with me
because the problem is like i can hear
them but i need to be actually tuned in
so i'm gonna go full gamer mode the
problem was that i was talking in the
middle of it and therefore i couldn't
hear anything so i'm going full
concentration
ah
huh
um
oh
good god good god good god
you did it
is so
proud of you
here
mommy has another hint for you
yeah what is it are you just gonna
dangle it in front of me you're gonna
dangle it again
that was actually legitimately tough
that was
that was tough
like if i hadn't been completely
concentrated and if i hadn't been
exactly tuned in with good headphones
because i was literally just like
blindly hitting in some of those hoping
that i got something and some of those i
had to hit twice did you guys notice
that
i'd call that a bit too difficult
hey
you've got really soft hands
you have uh
i don't know you just have really soft
hands i can
i can appreciate that i also have um
very soft hands
so
that's something that we have in common
and uh
i'd love to talk more about that with
you
okay anyway
all right
thank you for the hint i'm not going to
look at
[Music]
mommy it hoping you'd stay here forever
though
it's never too late to change your mind
i actually haven't made up my mind about
anything i don't really think that i'm
trying to escape out of here
um but at the same time
i i could stay you got you got food
i'm kind of hungry haven't eaten
anything since i got here
but uh alas oh well
oh the truest adventure line of them
allah
[Music]
no
i don't want to do that i don't want it
i don't want to do that
okay whatever
um
this looks fine
spooky
all right this looks like that level
from half-life like towards the end when
you're escaping from the lambda complex
there's something down here i feel like
there's something down there
i feel like there's something down here
oh come on
guys i'm just too tall
i'm just too tall i can't i can't fit
under here i could never i'm just too
tall
god oh man we'd love to get under there
but when you're this tall
sometimes you uh it's more of a burden
than anything to to not be able to get
under some things that are designed
obviously for
people over lower height hi speaking of
tall oh hey
okay
welcome back to the part
oh it's kissy oh it's kissy hi
you can't get me you're stuck behind oh
oh no
well i'm just gonna slip right by him
i'm just gonna slip oh are you opening
that for me oh
you're so sweet
now that's someone with power that you
could respect
now that's what it's all about that's
what it's all about
that's what it's all about hey thank you
for that
thank you
really
big preach
huge preach actually if you think about
it
barry
i can't go up there
all right
wham
bubbling
oh i see what needs to be
oh no
oh interesting okay
this place sounds a little ominous
i'm gonna go ahead and say that this
place is getting a little ominous
how does this help
how does this help me
okay if i had to think about this with
my big giant brain
ah i know
or do i
did i just solve it
hold on everybody hold on hold on don't
don't don't even try don't don't no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
i got this my big brain
oh it has it has this
i've got this in the bag
i've i've got this
100 i have this i see the connection
here and now i see it all unfolding in
front of me like
origami
in my mind
i see it
actually if origami is unfolding that's
things going wrong
which is exactly what's going on in my
head and you wouldn't even understand
the levels at which i am already
outpacing
this puzzle
i don't want to hear i'm not looking
i know look i never look i would never
ever in a million years
look
at what you are telling me right now at
this moment i don't need to look because
i've already got the solution
to this here that door closes and that's
good because that's exactly what i
wanted to do because i already know
the different levels at which i will be
able to solve this and when i solve it
hold on everybody you don't have any
clue of what i am capable of there's
nothing that i wouldn't do to stop
myself from getting success i
have it in
my head i go here i charge this i put it
here but alas i don't have enough charge
for that but aha i already know the
solution because this
is connecting me to the solution right
here and therefore i would be able to
solve it without any further delay
there's nothing that i could do
and then you oh of course and then you
go and then you take the
i'll never look i will do this with my
eyes closed so easy it isn't that's how
much i've got this solved
there's oh yeah
it's all coming together now you take uh
the round peg square hole triangle
shaped here you've got the ah the pitter
patter of the concrete falling down on
the wall there's
this
[Music]
and then you put this in there but when
you put that there you can't put it
there because you could never put it
there
of course
you can't put it there because there's
no putting it there you would never put
it there because put it there it's just
the most impossible thing that you could
ever do how could you put
[Music]
putting it there
is the crime
it was always a lie
there was never anything to do about it
anyway
that's the truth of it that's when we
all need to realize this game perfectly
encapsulates the futility of
continuing to move forward the only
answer is to not play this is the actual
end of the game it's so perfect it's
beautiful there is no progressing
forward
of course i've solved it there is no not
solving it i would never not solve it
because i've never not solved anything
in my life no puzzle is too much for me
to be able to solve and therefore the
only answer
is that there is no solution of course
of course it's so clear it's so clear
now how can i not see it how can i not
see that this is the only way forward is
to not go forward at all going forward
is actually the illusion that
that's clever that is clever that is
incredibly clever and i can't believe
that they would
ever not think that i could never not do
that for the entirety of the time that i
would not do that
it's almost criminally genius
okay
ah right well oh you think you're so you
think you're so oh you think you're so
you think you're so but no one's ever
thought they were so before and no so
has that ever been so whatever so to be
so
so
oh the souls
oh the souls oh the souls that they do
so and when you sow you reap and you
reap what you sow
and the souls you have the shows and you
take the souls and you ah
oh yes of course
how could i be so blind
he was right in front of me all along
all along
but but then but then but then and only
then
only then
only then do you see
oh yes
ah
[Laughter]
ah
yes barry
[Laughter]
yes of course yes
i'm supposed to get oh
anyway what why did i build this
oh no sir
that's what i like to hear
so
marcus
what happened
is he i was heading home for the day
when my apart realized that i left my
bloody wallet in the cafeteria
so i'm running through the lobby and
that's when i see it
a map handle lodged under the innovation
wingate
so what'd you do marcus
well i just thought i'd nab the bloody
yo could be on me merry way
and
well
i'm reaching for the thing and the mob
handled joel's on its own
had me scared stiff i i thought i was
the only one there
so i i took a peeking pin eat the gate
and some massive bloody thing was
gathering about the bloody hallway
thing
you're sure it wasn't a person
he's no person that's 50 feet long with
a thousand legs marcus you're losing me
maybe you just saw a bunch of people
walking by
look it wasn't people all right i happen
to bloody notion what it was but i
wasn't human
who have you told about this
besides me obviously
just you sir
obviously
okay i'll have security skim the cameras
and take a look
what
there's a massive bloody
monster
skimming ain't gonna get rid of it
you're on a line marcus we make toys not
monsters now come on get out of my sight
actually uh grab me a coffee will you
actually never mind get out of my sight
man that that is fantastic i think they
went up to sean they were like hey
you're irish right
wouldn't you play that
how irish can you go can you take your
irish slider and just like all the way
all the way past 100 just like
crank that irish up
that was very good i did like that
very good very good okay so i i
obviously know how to solve this and i
almost solved it already before
because it seems like there's a bit of
time bleeding going on here for you to
zap at the zap and then you would give
me you and wham and then pull this here
quickly yoink come on go now barry
oh you're fine
i thought barry was about to die
and i was worried
for barry
anyway barry time to die
bye barry
there goes barry
hello
barry
i
really
really want to throw myself into this
pit
i like i
really
really
truly
have never wanted to do anything more
than throw myself
into this bit
i have
never
in my life
cannonball
[Applause]
i can take it
i just wanted to see how much my body
could handle i just wanted to see how
much
i just want to see how much i can do oh
barry
berry
bye barry all right
okay where am i now
hole
anybody in the darkness
okay bye
hey look i'm back here
good at least i'll never have to worry
about all that nonsense ever again
but there still is a curiosity of why is
my microphone all kinds of
wonky what
why are why are you like that
i still don't understand what uh kissy
kissy
wissy missy kissy
wait what the hell
has that always been there
how's that always been
hmm
oh this is part of that code thing
right
staff
only
how do i get over there
i would have to do some crazy parkour ah
invisible wall they didn't want anyone
jumping all right fine then
last one i
[Music]
geez
think
you played these before you're so good
seems like you're ready for the final
game statues
follow mommy down the stairs one last
time
i hope you had a fun day at the game
station
see you next time
i alright
okay
uh
[Music]
am i doing this wrong what is this
what are you with
what
oh two hands apparently
i needed two hands for that one
ah good enough
oh no
oh no
oh no do you think poochie was mad at me
for uh
leaving him
behind do you think
maybe is this a 3d printer
parameter bat batari
parameter batari
parameter
that's not how you spell battery
but batari
batari
batari
batari atari
batari
oh
oh your eyes are
with
terrifying
what
caterpillar or bug
i'm crawling on all 400s
ah
my bones are way too dense you know how
much milk i drink you have no idea you
could not handle my bones
[Music]
nope
okay but that way no that's not right
that's a different thing
what do you do
what are you doing ah okay
well that's interesting but how do i
take advantage of that that's gonna be a
bit of a bit of a tricky one
okay
can i at least get up here yeah okay so
i can get up here
but what does that mean when i'm up here
i go here
grab that
you
there
oh
damn it
also why why is this suddenly
ungrabbable just because the light's not
on that doesn't make any sense why would
that be ungrabbable
that doesn't make any sense
come on
got it you there
hup
got you
easy easy give me a challenge next time
give me something tough
oh my god
what am i hearing
what nightmare am i hearing
what nightmare am i hearing
what am i hearing
what did i do
what did i do
oh no
it's the playground from security breach
oh
welcome to statues
this advanced obstacle course is
designed to test your physical endurance
and
strength the rules are simple
the lights will turn off
you can move through the obstacle course
at this time
however when the lights turn on you can
look around but cannot move
you may move again once the lights turn
back off
the lovable pj pug pillar will follow
you
if pj reaches you your test is over
that's all
good luck okay cool
oh hi look
pet boy good boy
hey who's a good puppy who's a good
puppy who is a good
[Music]
was puppy so sad to see the kids go
they called me mommy because i was the
closest thing they ever had to one
but they'd come for games
and never come back
they left mommy to die alone
mommy didn't deserve that
but you
you worked here
so if anyone deserves to die alone
it's you
i worked here man i must have been a bad
employee
okay so uh
who do i go now is now when i go isn't
it
now when we go we're going down we gotta
go down now
[Music]
hit me hard and heavy let's go baby
let's go go go can i grab these
i'm not moving
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god i'm not moving i would never
move i would never dream of moving why
would i be moving
oh let's go let's go
oh my god i didn't do it it's not me i'm
not moving i'm physically not moving
i'm going hard baby hard that's what i
do that's what i do all the time
[Music]
let's go baby let's go
[Music]
let's go the way the statue let's go
let's go oh god that was wrong i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry for everything
i've never wanted to do anything more
than what i'm doing right now
i'm not moving
okay here we go here we go here we go
yes yes yes
who would ever thought that i would be
winning at life and this game
and all what
and always in forever oh god i'm so slow
please let me get up on this
hop
oh my whole life i've been
training for this moment oh my god go
what what
calm is the seat
calm as the sea
calm
as the sea
calm is the sea
there's the summer breeze
here i
ah there i go where am i going where am
i i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
stuck i'm stuck why am i stuck why am i
stuck
why am i stuck why am i stuck
oh my god oh my god are you serious are
you serious are you
cannot be serious with this this is
baloney why would i be stuck
where am i going
[Music]
where what
i'm guys i'm uh a bearer of bad news
[Music]
i think i'm supposed to go that way
but unfortunately
it seems like i might be uh
what is happening
oh god oh god
the light's on or off i can't even tell
okay so let's just go to the right here
i'm not sure i understand
am i grabbing that
i am i
[Music]
what
what
all right
[Music]
yeah baby
yeah baby
we did it
i am the goddamn best what am i doing
[Music]
oh did i just break my legs
i mean it's a pinky promise guys
pinky
i'll come back
oh oh god
never mind i guess i'm swinging
you get to watch
i i totally would but it doesn't seem
like there's a way for me to do that
i'm legitimately trying but you know
whatever nope
oops
i uh
i didn't do that right
i didn't do that right
i was trying to go but i was trying to
do what she asked me to she asked so
nicely
it was very nice so why would i ever
disobey
oh my god
i'm not good at the swing swung
oh
great whatever the hell that means
i have no idea
oh god
okay whatever
here we go again
ah
i am the best
ah the whole family end up
baby
look at the baby that baby's gonna grow
up to be a nightmare
okay i was so confused there for a
second because okay let me explain why i
was confused
so you got
mommy here and this must be daddy and
this must be baby right
daddy's hand is yellow
but the baby was yellow
i was extremely confused as to what the
hell was going on there anyway
moving
on geez
it's okay uh
spaghetti lady
it's uh it's wonderful
i'll uh i'll be back later
i'll be back at another time just
definitely don't follow me
we'll walk down this dark hallway
nothing okay whatever
well this is
this uh
is quiet
i don't like this
um
i'm gonna go ahead and say i
i
oh okay good i was so confused there i
thought okay
cool good
great
to be perfectly honest that room where i
confused myself is like the scariest
thing
it's the scariest thing that i face in
this whole game so far
can i not go
here hello
okay
um
all right i'm just gonna
go
[Music]
that's a cool valve
why is this why is it so quiet
why is it so quiet
it's very quiet
there are tape here somewhere
i have not looked at my things here
mommy long legs has the unique ability
to stretch okay stretch any of her limbs
for several hundred feet this includes
her fingers arms hair neck waist and
legs she's very hostile towards the
staff but is very motherly and acts
warmly towards the other experiments she
is protective of them the hostility is
quickly becoming problematic but perhaps
there's a solution to put her in place
her place mommy longlegs would be
perfect for facilitating everything with
the children in the game station she has
the warmth that a mother should and any
rowdy child can learn to listen to their
mother it makes sense that her seeing
these children daily would improve her
behavior and it is very unlikely she
will act out in front of the children
have her transferred to high security
maintenance immediately conditioning can
begin
okay sure
what am i doing water treatment
ah it's some kind of a puzzle
some kind of a crazy puzzle
so what do i need i don't know what i
need do i need to get back to the game
station what is that thing over there
let me go take a look first and then
i'll get there later
uh
okay i mean it's very pretty i
i think
what is this
toy scanner
i know oh right that was in the first
game where you needed a toy
swip
the prototype the prototype has saved us
i agree isn't he wonderful
sure
absolutely what are you talking about
what do you what do you mean
what do you mean
what you mean
the prototype has saved us okay so i
need to go to the game station or over
there
and apparently i can't just make that
jump which is strange which means that i
need to rotate
boink
boink
god damn i'm good god damn i'm good must
be all this sleep i'm getting
by the way did you guys know i've been
sleeping very well lately
it's been wonderful i used to only get
like uh
five maybe six hours of sleep a day
but lately
i've been sleeping like a dream i can't
just grab that i can't just grab that
i could grab it
i will catch it
yep it has been very nice like i'm not
gonna lie
oh oh did that change something you know
oh
okay so it's it this is some kind of a
puzzle where i got to solve this out
this is probably going to take me a bit
yeah
yeah i know right it's it's kind of i
can't do that it's illegal what sleeping
eight hours my god after 10 hours at 10
years ish actually more than 10 years of
not sleeping for eight hours a night
no thank you
after uh like 10 years of not sleeping
well it's uh it's been really nice to
just be able to do what i need to do
wait go to my inventory what do you mean
i didn't get it yet
i did not get it
i did not get it
yeah so so what happened is uh like
because i i have adhd
if you couldn't tell from this
playthrough and uh
like for the past uh since i got
diagnosed when i was like 20 i believe
i've been taking adderall which is a
medication that i take
but lately i switched up to this new one
of stars and i've been able to actually
sleep which is fascinating and
incredible and makes me realize like
holy [ __ ]
i really have needed to get a lot more
sleep lately because i've just been in a
much better mood it's been fantastic
actually so it's been uh been really
nice
where the hell are you going i need you
to
you're going there wouldn't that drop it
right on me
wait did i do it you go up there
oh wait oh i see wait
ah
you go there
ah
really can i not hit that
can i not hit that
how can i not hit that
oh okay so you
see
up down up what does this
[Applause]
oh oh weird
wait a minute where does that go then
give
hey
anyway
wait there's something
oh you guys shouldn't be giving me any
kind of a hint
that's not what this is about
really
there we go i bet i can't jump down
there
okay thank you
thank you very much
i'll be on my way then goodbye i have a
toy now i would like to redeem it
please
how am i gonna do this
[Music]
oh
yes i'm so smart
i'm so smart
tape
i'm getting a a message from
you're gonna put an invisible what a
cheap
thing to do
what a cheap
thing to do i could
obviously
make that jump
that is clearly a jump i can make you
put an invisible wall there
what is wrong with you what is wrong
with you
what is wrong with you
what is wrong with you okay apparently
there was some kind of a tape that i
missed and i gotta
make sure that i get it
so uh that i don't miss it
that would be devastating if i missed it
all right now that the proper things
have been aligned i can actually go down
here and i can
oh i can just make sure that i go get
this tape that is oh so important who do
you think i am matpat you're probably
one of those types of things mac is
better than me
there is absolutely no way that mac
would ever be better than me so you can
just uh
you can just forget about that idea
there
my strategy of uh being an incredible
youtuber and puzzle solver i don't see
any tape here guys
i'm beginning to think i'm being trolled
here there's
there's no tape there's just no tape
here guys
there's no tape
there's no tape guys i'm sorry
there is not a tape here
wow okay let me see if i can look again
what oh nope i don't see anything no
tape here no tape there
no tape anywhere
man
you know what
looks like there's no tank
looks like there's no tape at all
it's all right chat you know we all have
dumb moments it just seems that you have
a few more dumb moments than everyone
else
[Laughter]
it's all right guys don't beat
yourselves up for it don't beat
yourselves up it's okay we all fail
sometimes i don't fail that much uh but
oh my god guys
you were totally wrong it wasn't even in
that room guys it's okay
really it's totally fine guys the tape
is right here i know that's hard for you
to see i get it and you're not used to
like playing games like this uh but me
being the eagle-eyed person that i am
wow i found the tape
so uh you're welcome i'm sorry you
didn't see it i'm sorry you tried to
mislead me you you almost got me there
you almost got me there but honestly
you got to be a little more clever than
that you got to be quicker than that
quicker on your feet anyway here we go
jimmy your work as playtime co's chief
marketing officer has skyrocketed the
company's profits how do you do it
you know it's not what you'd expect it's
the little things most people don't even
think about like take names for example
express people up and realize this you
take the e sound slap it on the end of a
name boom you're making bank
huggy
mommy even elliot knew this way back
with poppy i guess like blue blue is
huge i'm telling you what's your
favorite color blue i bet it's blue
right it's blue it's green
okay well your special case most people
would say blue but seriously marketing
is not as easy as you think i make it
look easy if there's anything playtime
code should be known for it's not toys
it's marketing
wow that was so worth it i'm really glad
that i did that
really glad that i went through all that
trouble um that made me feel good about
me and my accomplishments
so uh
thanks
all right now we're going to do this and
not jump off into the ether because we
finally have a toy
blep
[Music]
so
you see how that was your fault right
and i'll explain it you probably don't
but you see
if you guys
hadn't misled me into thinking that the
tape was over here in the room that i
just was
i would not have tried to make that jump
and then i would not have died to an
invisible wall that the developer should
never have put there in the first place
therefore therefore it is entirely 100
percent your fault that this has
occurred and i
will be placing full blame on your
culpable shoulders not capable i'm not
saying capable i'm saying culpable as in
the culpability
for the crime
is on your shoulders and therefore all
punishment for this
should be
to
you
and you should feel so
incredibly
unbelievably ashamed of yourselves and
each other and if there's one person in
here that should feel no shame it's me
and i don't
i feel no shame ever
i've never felt shame a day in my life
not once
[Music]
[Music]
hey
that sounded familiar wait that toy
sounds sounded familiar
okay anyway now that you guys are done
sabotaging my adventure here i'm gonna
get back on track
and i will put do i have a toy and i do
have a toy three plus toys okay i'm good
i'm good
by the way everyone i am back officially
for my space trip
i am uh
very happy to report that i am in fact
back
regular videos will
be resuming
oh god what have i done
oh no i'm good okay
we'll be resuming as of uh
the video i posted before this if you
didn't know i posted the uh the stanley
parable the full game also earlier today
so i am extremely very much back
wow
oh okay all right that was it unlocking
okay good
oh good great
where are you leading me and why is it
to my death
but what was this nah i don't trust it
but what was that other one
what was the other path there
why did you have anything if you weren't
going to give me another path
why did you tempt me with something that
was there right away oh i gotta go back
whatever
whatever
whatever
why am i here
what am i looking at over there with the
wheelchair and the like medical screen
that's curious
now that actually piques my curiosity
what is that
am i a real boy
the robot crossed the road
he was programmed to do it
i love you
do you love me
no
dance with me
no
the button hurts me
okay that's weird all right so there's a
tape here somewhere and that's there
somewhere
okay so i need to do something about all
of this nonsense and eventually probably
open up this door or go through this
area or
i can't put my hand through there okay
interesting i am sprinting through the
vents
i'm going very quickly don't know how i
did this
speed runner strap
okay so there's got to be some kind of a
power well there's that power
but unfortunately
oh i see they want me to swing across
well little did they know that they
actually gave me
a uh ladder so i'm gonna use it
see swinging is for uh chumps and uh i
ain't no chump
because if i uh
uh
pull
pull
pull
so if i oh no
oh no
oh no
oh
oh my god oh my god
i'm alive
i'm not alive oh my god where am i why
am i not alive
oh i'm alive
i don't know how i did that
oh god
i don't know what i'm doing somehow i
found a way to like counteract my
falling motion if i'm still holding
something there's something to that i
don't know what it is but there's
something to that
okay so i gotta get this door open
somehow
and in order to do that i'm willing to
bet that it's something like this won't
open until that yeah okay
so that's gonna open and then i need to
get back basically
but that is closed off there
so i need to do this oh
slam that in there that opens that
and then
need to while that's doing that
uh complete the circuit
boom
i did it i did it
i don't know what i did but i did it
what did i do
what did i do
i turned on the lights in there that's
what i did
strange
it was closing which is closed
huh
what did i do
i hate that i can't tell what i did
what did i just do
what it
what did i do
i don't know what i did besides open up
these doors that i already already
opened up before is it opening us up
something over here okay
ow
all right oh i have a flashlight now in
what world
how did i get a flashlight that doesn't
make any sense that does that
that makes zero sense uh whatever you
know it's fine
it's fine
oh no
hello
oh my god hey
and you cheated i didn't cheat
caesars
now
we're going to play one last game okay
[Music]
what are you going to do
what are you going to do
what are you going to do
oh
i see
that's what you're going to do this
isn't about i i beg to differ
i think this is exactly about me
i think this is exactly about me
[Music]
anyway
all right cool
it's called
speed run
three am i supposed to actually hide
what am i supposed to actually do
am i hiding or am i running away very
quickly because those are two very
different things
it seems like i'm running away very
quickly
but alas not that quickly where do i go
from here
i might be boned i'm not boned
i guess i go here
it's awfully quiet
i feel like i should be chased by
something very loud and menacing
but it does not seem that i'm being
chased by anything loud and menacing
in fact it seems awfully peaceful here
if i didn't know any better i'd say that
this was a pretty advent adventurous
adventure down
some kind of
random place
oh this seems familiar oh i definitely
know about this oh
well it's a good thing i don't care
about collectibles
um
that did nothing
i really feel like there should be some
intensity happening here
i feel like i should be like oh my god
i'm going to die whoa
you know what i mean i feel like
hmm
interesting bay 2
well
blue green
that's obvious
but i don't have red yellow hands
wait
oh god it's always with the up
what is with that oh
okay red
red blue green
that's good enough
red
blue
green
yellow
that uh
that should have been obvious
that's on me guys that's on me
again i feel like i'm missing some of
the intensity here
oh hey whoa that's a problem okay well
uh
boy
there's the intensity ladies and
gentlemen we found it we did it we oh
god ectoplasmic goo
someone
all over
[Music]
right i was supposed to go up and then
down that's what i thought for a second
like uh but
but i thought um
i thought that there was uh something
else going on there something else uh
equally as spicy as what that were
so uh there you have it
okay take two
yipes
oh no
yeah she's actually pretty freaky
i mean you already knew that she kind of
freaky
missed me [ __ ] oh my god okay i am
supposed to
or i thought i
i didn't know i was supposed to stay
there
i thought that i was supposed to
i was
i thought that that was what i was
supposed to do
turns out it's the cowardly path that is
the correct one which i fundamentally
disagree with
you know what i mean i think it's a
little silly it's a little cliche if you
ask me anyway
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i see i see i see
web coast is clear let's keep going then
i'm sure that she won't be down this
path that i first encountered her in
surely this would be i feel that that
would have been a lot better if i did
have to get behind her and run away as
she was still chasing me that would have
kept the intensity up you know how i am
about intensity
ensure that machinery is clear of debris
white machines for surfaces of lubricant
dirt now they're loosely checked replace
worn damaged parts machinery fluid
levels check bolts for damage main gear
removed damage beyond repair please
replace asap all right i need to find a
gear
looks like i need a gear well i found a
gear that was a lot easier than i
thought it would be
okay that's not the right gear then
interesting
good thing i have plenty of time to deal
with this
i think
i'm looking up i'm looking up i'm
looking up at all the op i'm looking
very up
oh look at all this up
ah
oh okay i've looked up
hey y'all
whoa
okay
um
seems to be some fire in the way
oh good the fire's gone
well um
[Music]
i'm not sure what that's about
at least that's a
what
what
what what what what what am i looking at
what is that coal or something i don't
know what that is
that's weird
don't know what's going on there
okay well that uh it's a big nipple
inside of a furnace which as you know is
standard procedure for a boiler room um
everybody knows this
uh
drag this
looks like we got another puzzle on our
hands boys something about a ladder i'm
i'm probably going to need a ladder let
me pull this lap i can't use that ladder
okay hold on everybody hold on
everybody hold on i'm looking up i'm
looking up look at all the up that i'm
looking at i'm looking at all this up oh
my god the up
man the up has been so looked at right
now i've never looked more up than i am
looking right now down it was a trick i
needed to look down all along
i needed to look down because looking
down was exactly where i needed to look
up
or maybe
maybe it's a factor of turning this on
there can be fire in there
and then when that's going this is hot
up here i stick my head in here
and then
and only ah oh
yes
i did it what did i
do oh
i don't know how that works but i got it
and
wham
hey hey
look at
look at me
all right ben
whatever
purge my adhd for five minutes i cannot
i cannot
no no no this is me this is me focus
guys you don't understand i've been more
focused oh my god oh no it's fine
no it's not fine
here
here
you're putting me here
oh good good good good yes no maybe so
maybe
all right
okay
don't worry about it
i got this
wham bam thank you ma'am no this this is
me focused
[Laughter]
no no no this is this is this is oscar's
focus here this is medicated focus this
is a hundred percent going for it so i
am i am very very
very focused everyone i am i am
perfectly pleased with what
kind of focus i have right now
okay so um
i got it okay
i think i got i i i know what to do
i do i actually do
unless being in there would kill me if
it was on
maybe i could i could i was going to
light this when i was in here which
still might be the correct strategy
because there is that time delay i do
feel
what are the odds what are the odds what
are the i'm up
i'm gonna um should i just oh she could
open the door i'm gonna light it on fire
i'm gonna light it on fire
i'm gonna light it on fire
come on baby
burn baby burn
i'm gonna close the door as well
100 that was the fire and not the doors
no one can prove otherwise that was
absolutely one thousand percent the fire
and not the doors okay that was one
million and a half percent the fire and
not the doors
confirmed pro fire strat
100 speed run absolutely god tier
strategies was the fire and no one can
say otherwise if anyone does say
otherwise they are a criminal and they
should be punished
accordingly
oh god where am i going i don't even
know where i'm at
punished accordingly
oh
oh be careful i'm very oh
come on
come on
really i never look up
i never look why would i look up
why would i look up why would i ever
look up oh good i'm running no i'm not
it's all a lie
i'm going now
[Music]
oh my god oh really oh my are you
kidding me
go go go go
right where am i going oh
wow
okay okay all right
see what's funny about this
is
this chase has exactly the same
criticisms i had about chapter ones
chase
and it's like
[Music]
it's not like i'm not fine with it i'll
talk about it later
let me just get through this
at no point in your really cool chase
sequence should you have players going
like
oh i guess i'll get through this
oh just kidding
oh really
i will oh i'll give my thoughts oh don't
worry
i'll give my thoughts
once i endure this chase sequence
once i bear the arduousness of this
chase sequence oh i'll give my thoughts
oh i'm going to give my thoughts
mommy's wrong apparently
oh i see
oh my god
okay
oh my god
okay
here i go
hey look at that they made it
i made it
oh
yeah
excellent
oh
oh oh
oh no
[Applause]
oh no
oh no
oh
oh oh oh god
[Music]
you're all right oh my god oh my god
oh my god
cool
peekaboo
[Music]
okie dokie then
up i look up no i look right that was
the correct answer i'll get it right
someday guys don't you worry about that
huh
well this has a sense of finality to it
this is just purely leading me to jump
off here that's all this is purely
leading me to jump off 100
a weed
whoa
the mommy toy is missing her head
interesting
there's another vcr here
it's not sure where the tv is
where's the tv oh there we go
lot code 08502
in relation
experiment 1006
the prototype
a close call occurred this week in which
he nearly breached containment
the prototype seemingly disassembled the
digital alarm clock within his room and
utilized the battery
along with several other components to
create a laser pointer
which he then fired into the security
camera disabling it
these actions allowed him 28.3 seconds
completely unmonitored
once function returned to the camera the
room appeared to be empty
one surveillance specialist went in to
confirm his absence
however upon opening the door she
realized that the prototype had hidden
in one of the camera's blind spots
the prototype attempted to escape
through the open door however
another surveillance specialist was able
to remotely re-lock the door
despite the other specialists still
being inside
one casualty occurred
the prototype seems to possess an
unprecedented level of intelligence
beyond that of all other test subjects
as well as an alarming willingness to
commit violence
further suppression treatments will need
to be enacted to ensure that no other
experiments develop these qualities
experiment one one seven zero huggy
wuggy remains the optimal outcome due to
his sufficient intelligence paired with
maximum obedience
end of luck
okay interesting
all right all uh we seem to be
approaching the end of this but uh i'll
give my conclusionary thoughts at the
conclusion
i will be able to summarize everything
yes yes i will
don't you worry your pretty little heads
we are approaching the end of this game
i think
i mean now that mommy is in
pieces i'm assuming
oh hi
hello
oh
what
what oh
no
good no she died
see i never trusted you and now you're
talking like
like a
maniac why would you talk like that what
why would you talk like that proctoring
in the game station proctoring
proctoring
stella gray bear
i can't zoom into that why can't i now
zoom into that
i don't know
yoink
well i ain't doing nothing here
bam
nothing
so do i just board the train and that's
um
hippity hop to the candy shop hey buddy
yeah baby hop
hippity hippity hop
oh hey
wow
probably
smoke weed every day
okay sure
ah this is where i popped out i knew it
was around here somewhere
hey look at that
so the train sequence is
okay so one two three four
actually have to i see okay
okay that's right order we're looking at
the colors red
red red
blue
and then one two three four
one
two three four
engaged and engaged
yes
and we're going
well this seems good i'm sure nothing
bad can happen now
i'm looking up
okay
i was so scared she put me back in that
case
but you saved me
you are perfect
too perfect to lose
i'm sorry
i can't let you leave
i've never met anyone like you
yeah i'm pretty great you know how long
i've been stuck in that case yeah well
too long
i had so much time to think and reflect
time to figure out exactly what i would
do and free
will set things right
terrible things have happened
but i know that whatever i need you to
do i'm looking up
you are capable
we will
what
what
where am i oh
what huh
oh
hello
time to wake up i don't know what's
going on
oh
[Laughter]
no man why would i stop this
let's keep it going baby
unsafe speeds this is hilarious
that's so funny
god if you don't do anything nothing
happens
ah man that really robs the intensity of
the moment don't it
this is the same as same as uh uh ladies
spaghetti holding the note out for me
and me just not taking it this is
funny
i want to go faster oh we go faster come
on let's keep going
baby all right fine
this is really funny to me
all right now we're cooking with gas
turns out that was the go faster button
and it's nap time
hello
blake
up
and there you have it
that
was poppy playtime chapter two now i'm
certain that there's going to be an
after credits thing but before we get to
that
what i would like to say about this is
uh because i know that a lot of people
are upset about this company for a lot
of reasons and i i get it i think nfts
are stupid um and and all the things
about like uh
whatever else happened with it are
probably legitimately legitimate
criticisms but what i always try to
remember is that a company is not one
hive mind
there was clearly a lot of work and love
that was put into this game that's
that's what i really want to emphasize
look at these credits these are all the
people the people that worked on this
game the people that put time in and i'm
all about like if if if any of it was
like not paying these people properly
that is awful you should pay people what
they're worth but the problem with it
and i get the kind of like protesting it
of things um but what it comes down to
is
these people that actually put in the
time
they put it into something that i'm sure
that they are very proud of so i want to
celebrate them
for making the thing in the first place
the actual artists behind making it um
as opposed to high-level executive
decisions that may or not be stupid i
was wrong there's nothing after the
credits i'm an idiot so anyway
that's why i played it i think it's
still like there's a lot of really
creative ideas i think the developers
have an opportunity to redeem themselves
um because they do have something
creative there's a lot of inspiration
from five nights at freddy's there's a
lot of inspiration from scp i see that i
can see it with the prototype test 1077
or whatever it was i can see that there
clearly is some underlying threads that
you can see from other popular
properties and that's not a bad thing
it's putting a creative spin on it all
of creativity is just kind of like
rehashing what has come before but
putting it in a new package and there's
clearly style here now the chase
sequence god damn it this is my biggest
problem with chase sequences in general
you can have a chase sequence and it can
be fun and cinematic but the problem
with the chase sequence is it is
inherently self-defeating
always i have seen so few well-executed
chase sequences because the problem is
you have so many cool things happening
and the player can never look at them
you spent all this time i saw the corner
of my eye like
the lady spaghetti crown on the a wall
there but if you take a second to look
at it you die you ruin the experience
because you reset you don't have time to
think on your feet which is like the
whole point it's a reactionary thing but
the problem with change sequences is it
if it's smart it combines things that
you know have been taught throughout the
experience but it's just like man just
like the first
poppy play time i probably cut out way
more times than i actually died in that
one but anyway
it is what it is i thought that was a
really cohesive and very polished
experience i i didn't think it was as
scary as like the first one it did have
some moments of good like creepiness to
it um but i think it was probably
lacking in a lot of like the super
grounded scare factor and also sean was
in it mr jacksepticeye himself was there
proud and irish extremely irish and i
think that's pretty cool
so yeah
i am back from my vacation we are back
to the regular schedule videos on the
daily every daily from now until
whenever youtube shuts down
thank you everybody so much for watching
this video if you want to see chapter
one you have to go into my channel and
find it if you want to see in space with
markiplier go into my channel and find
it we got content being pumped out as
hard as content can pump and i can pump
content hard so that's exactly what i'm
gonna do cool stuff on the horizon too
thank you all so much for being here and
enjoying the cool stuff that i make
there was way too many of you at this
and uh there probably will be way too
many of you uh watching stuff in the
future but thanks for being here
remember i'm markiplier your lightning
rod of hate i have two podcasts if you
didn't know distractible and go my
favorite sports team have you been
keeping up with those while i was on
working out in space i bet you didn't
goddamn it i'll make a third podcast if
i have to and you're gonna listen to it
good because
i love working with my friends and they
are really funny and i really cherish
the time that we're able to spend
together so go listen to distractible go
listen to go my favorite sports team my
podcast with tyler if you haven't heard
of tyler in a while
hey we've got a podcast together where
we talk about sports it's a lot of fun
you'll enjoy it even if you don't like
sports and if you like the insanity of
bob wade and i go check out distractable
and hey
thanks so much for being here
hope you had fun i had a lot of fun and
it's good to be back
so
go stream uh i'm back baby and give
everyone who is a part of uh in space
with markiplier a lot of love and give
yourself some love too you deserve it
all right i'm gonna get out of here
remember everything i said and spread
the word about everything i said
literally every word that i said in the
stream i want rehashed and reposted
everywhere
that's your homework
all right
i'll be checking your work tomorrow
let's hope you get a passing grade
you better
or else
don't
[Music]
fail
do
[Music]
succeed